hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar PCR testing reveals that SCC is
not so golden of a standard of care
I'm antonina Salcido of lab roots and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by Thermo Fisher Scientific
to learn more please visit
thermofisher.com
now let's get started
I'd like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you would like at any time
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click Send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
I now present today's speakers Dr Becky
Winslow clinical science liaison at
acutis and Dr mayel Sean mugam senior
scientist and director of molecular and
microbiology
for complete biography on our speakers
please visit the biography tab at the
top right of your screen
Dr Winslow you may now begin your
presentation
hi my name is Dr Becky Winslow and I am
Dr mayiel will be discussing with you
today polymerase Chain Reaction testing
and how it reveals the standard urine
culture is not so golden of a standard
of care
foreign
so let's jump right into the impacts of
urinary tract infection as they are
quite extensive
urinary tract infection affects
approximately 150 million people
worldwide
urinary tract infection is also the most
common outpatient bacterial infection in
the U.S
urinary tract infection leads to two to
three million emergency department
visits per year
it leads to approximately 10.5 million
office visits per year
it causes 3.5 billion in health care
related costs annually
and last but certainly not least urinary
tractor infection leads to Workforce
presenteeism and absenteeism
so let's look at the standard uriculture
and some of the technical challenges
associated with the standard urine
culture
true or false the standard urine culture
was validated for use in identifying
lower urinary tract microorganisms
what do you think
false
the standing urine culture was not
actually validated for use identifying
lower urinary tract microorganisms
yet for more than 60 years the medical
community has relied upon the standard
urine culture for identifying Euro
pathogens
the standard urine culture was never
validated for use and identifying lower
urinary tract infections like bladder or
urethral infections
and those are cystitis in particular
represent the majority of urinary tract
infections
so let's look at why the gold standard
for identifying uropathogens is not so
golden after all foreign
culture results in a high rate of false
negatives
why because the standard urine culture
is biased to grow E coli
and with standard culturing protocols in
place the standard urine culture will
not detect
slow growing organisms fastidious and
non-aerobic organisms and most
gram-positive organisms
the state of urine culture also can
misclassify polymicrobial infections as
sample contamination
it can take the standard urine culture
up to 72 hours for a turnaround time
and last but certainly not least
previous exposure to antibiotics or the
patient's urine exposure to antibiotics
can skew the culture's results
and the bottom line is that just because
pathogens have not grown in standard
urine culture over the last 60 years
does not mean that they were present in
samples and this has led to undiagnosed
and misdiagnose urinary tract infections
as well as antimicrobial resistance
so let's look at polymerase chain
reaction and its advantages in urinary
tract infection pathogen identification
the main take home that I want you to uh
have from this presentation is that
polymerase chain reaction is
advantageous because pathogen detection
and identification is not dependent on
the organism's growth and culture
so let's take just a minute to look at a
research study that compared PCR versus
culture
in a retrospective record review of 582
consecutive elderly patients presenting
with symptoms of lower urinary tract
infection
all patients had traditional urine
cultures and they also had PCR molecular
testing run in parallel
a urine pathogen was detected by PCR in
56 of those patients
and by traditional urine culture
the uropathogen was only detected in 37
of patients
that's quite a significant difference
when we're talking about clinical care
of a patient
now the PCR and culture agreed in 74 of
cases both 34 or positive and both 40
were negative
there was disagreement
between PCR and culture and that was 26
the PCR was positive and the culture was
negative in 22 percent of cases and the
PCR was negative and the culture was
positive in four percent of cases there
are reasons why
um a culture may be positive versus the
PCR being negative that goes beyond the
scope of this discussion and we won't um
cover that today we can cover that at a
later time foreign
microbial infections PCR detected
166 pathogens versus culture that
detected 39 packages
so these results suggest
that PCR may be likely to identify
pathogens before traditional culture
will
and this very last statistic is highly
clinically significant in that
polymicrobial infections were detected
in 12 of the samples in which the
culture had actually given a negative
test result
so for 12 of those samples or 12 of
those patients
they may have been not treated at all
for urinary tract infection when in fact
they had a polymicrobial infection
so let's just take a look
at the clinical Journey a patient would
experience
in which a subscriber a prescriber
excuse me
prescribed standard urine culture versus
PCR for Diagnostic testing
the standard UTI diagnostic workup looks
something like this
the patient presents with signs and
symptoms of lower urinary tract
infection
the doctor performs a urinalysis via
dipstick in the office
based on the urinary analysis results
the doctor may send the sample out to
the lab for a standard urine culture
the doctor will prescribe an empiric
antibiotic before the patient leaves the
office
and based on the standard urine culture
results the doctor will call the patient
in three to four days to de-prescribe
adjust or maintain the empiric
antibiotic
so the only change in this workup
procedure when a doctor decides to use
PCR testing is that they send the
patients urine sample for PCR testing at
a lab that provides PCR testing versus
sending for standard urine culture only
so you can see that PCR testing is not
disruptive to the standard UTI
diagnostic workout
now very importantly let's look at the
timeline for the patient for the
prescriber who uses PCR versus standard
urine culture to diagnose their urinary
tract infection
so let's say
let's say that lab a has PCR
urinary tract infection testing and lab
B has standard urine culture testing
only
okay on Day Zero the sample arrives at
the lab no matter which lab you send it
to on day one at the PCR lab the PCR ID
is reported a preliminary AST is
reported
however on day one at lab B
the sample is only being plated and to
run for culture
what happens on day two
at lab a the AST may be completed
depending on the pathogen but at lab B
you can see that the sample is still
running for culture
on day three at lab a with the PCR
testing AST is likely completed
completed depending on the pathogens
but down on day three at lab B the
sample is still running for culture and
the results might not be done
at lab B
you can see that on day four the sample
is still running for culture and the
results might not be done
on day five at lab B
the sample is running for culture the
results might not be done
and then on lab B the ID and the
standard urine culture guided AST report
may or may not be complete
so what is day one how does day one
compare for the PCR lab versus the
non-pcri
Ola there's a faster turnaround time to
Accurate identification of pathogens or
the absence of pathogens there's also a
faster turnaround time to de-prescribe
or prescribe
how about day two or three for the PCR
lab
star guided EST has accurately validated
or invalidated the prescriber's original
treatment selection
so this leads to a faster turnaround
time to prescribe or de-prescribe
let's look at the standard urine culture
day four five and six
a slower turnaround time to less
accurate identification of pathogens or
absence of pathogens
we also have a slower turnaround time to
prescribed or de-prescribed
so you can see from that uh timeline
that the PCR guided urinary tract
infection testing produces a faster
turnaround time for results and it also
leads to a faster deprescribe or
prescribed
so let's just look at a summary of how
PCR UTI testing can interrupt the
progress or the typical scenario which
is where standard urine cultures that
are undiagnosed or misdiagnosed can lead
to the negative clinical and economic
outcomes
if we use PCR instead of standard urine
culture for the identification of
uropathogens we're able to decrease the
negative clinical and economic
consequences that we see from the
standard urine culture
so now I'm going to hand over the
presentation to Dr myel Who will discuss
with you the rigorous scientific and
Regulatory validation that PCR testing
must overgo undergo and I want to
highlight before he starts how critical
it is to clinical outcomes from urinary
tract infections that these tests
undergo the scientific and Regulatory
validation process that he is going to
describe for you foreign
the asset performance we learn ourselves
and as a limitation and third of course
you have to get the regulatory approval
to run the asset So within that mind I
could name Market days we approach this
problem entirely different
we look at the essay as an entirety
rather than part by part for example in
Illinois track infection let us Define
first The Matrix then we have to Define
how we collect the sample and transport
you have to produce a document very
clear document to a regulatory agencies
how we are going to do it then the
sample requisition form how we are going
to supply this to the clients we want to
see how School looks like then in the
SOP you have to have a clear definition
for sample acceptance and a rejection
criteria
then stambers stability should be
defined as well which is we are going to
validate when you do the analytical
things
then based on the Matrix we have to
Define what are the interferraneous then
extraction process PCR
and results acceptance criteria
then we have to summate a report it's
not just a single report at least
minimum two report positive negative on
top of the top of that based on our
assay validation any interfering agent
which is lower your real body or any
cross reactive you have to give
additional example report then clearly
defined proficiency testing
S5 paste
uh next slide please
thank you
then we are preparing for the validation
when we prepare for the validation
we have to develop here validation plan
when you develop your validation plan
the first thing of course your testimony
for that you have to collect literature
you have to literature survey to show
the clinical relevance for that
particular analyte so you have to submit
those literature to the regulatory
agency
then here what we do normally we do the
theoretical L Body calculation the
reason is we want to take the assay
performance in our hand rather than
Dictator by itself
at the same time it's also going to
guide you if there is any problem in the
validation you have to troubleshoot
that's why our success here
next slide please
when you prepare the for the validation
the first thing of course Matrix the
regulatory agency they want to spike the
material or use any anything in the
assay is a negative Matrix
here the normal human tool to urine is
commercially available we also bought it
for the commercially one but we test it
out on the culture plate as well as in
the test system here in the
UDA testimony make sure that everything
is negative then we use the Matrix for
our experiment
so the Regulatory Agencies they want to
see the tighter intact organism
there is no synthetic DNA involved here
so only one case they are okay with that
is a genomic DNA for example the
mycoplasma it's very difficult to
culture at the time they are okay with
the genomic DNA other than that they
want to see all
analytes in Impact organism and it is
right now available from different
sources I listed few here
you can able to get
next slide please
so
the validation plans should include
specificity
so uh into a like inclusivity
exclusivity as well
and checkerboard sensitivity Precision
assay Enterprise agents accuracy and
stability
these things should included in the
validation plan
as selectors
so
on top of this validation the first
thing we focus on the extraction
we all know that not all microorganic
organisms are not going to realize
equally
for example gram positive organisms are
difficult to life
so to overcome the issue we are
going to usually optimize the extraction
for example if you have an uh on a drug
resistant organism from positive drug
resistant organism in some cases the
cell wall is modified
so
those organisms are not going to be Lies
by lysosome in the case we may have to
consider like neutralizing lysostopian
depends upon the organism so we want to
optimize first to make sure that we have
the ability to lies and isolate the
nucleic acids at the same time we also
focus on volume of beads if you are
using any bit based extraction and the
proton Escape of course we pay attention
in illusion volume which is going to
dictate finally for the
sensitivity of the asset
then we focus on controls apart from NTC
and NAC we pay attention in detail for
the spike in control the Regulatory
Agencies don't like to see
one city value and below
they want to see what is our acceptable
CP range we have to run the experiment
and so this is your acceptable City
range which is also applicable to your
positive control as well they want to
you have to Define very clearly in our
validation document
next slide please
so
we always run the specificity experiment
first
especially there are inclusivity
experiment if you are using open array
is an added Advantage because it's a
special Multiplex
so if you are testing one organism that
means you are testing against 55 other
different targets so that's an added
Advantage here
on top of that you have to select a few
more organisms genetically related
organisms commonly found in The Matrix
to demonstrate your assay performance
it's really good
don't forget to include human DNA
the reason is there is not just a
specificity sometimes a human DNA can
interfere in your assay so one
experiment can be reused in the assay
Enterprise agents next slide please
so after you run the specifications
then we move to the sensitivity the
sensitive requirements are 6 to 10 point
dilution phase betterment my Testo panel
is too big usually UTI is going to be
more than 30 organisms that means
there's a lot of testing how we overcome
this so what we do is we make a pool of
organisms when you make the pool
we want to make sure that they are
generically distinct
then you can run the sensitivity this
way we can reduce the time and reduce
the amount of money you spend to run
this experiment usually we combine L
Body and the Precision together so that
your validation progress really fast and
save money
natural place
so accuracy there is a linear clicker
sample no
can try to sample this accept that only
if you spike those material in negative
Matrix it should be expected at least
two different concentrations near and
above one above dialogue
they need meaning they want to see
minimum of 30 samples per analyte
so
on top of that you need a 30 negative
sample for the two by two table analysis
could be collected some reference
material from another collaboratory used
in the experiment when you do those
things collect the report as well
de-identify report you need to further
submission
next slide please
then stability the stability must be
defined in two way one at a room
temperature and a representation
plus you need to establish the nucleic
acid stability what we did here
we did four times freeze the cycle
then we'd analyze and then we
demonstrated the nucleic acids were
stable
when finally you do the data analysis we
have to pay attention and data it should
be analyzed specific and you have to
present every single data in a table for
what in clear way
with that I'll show you one last slide
which contains some clinical data that's
like this
so these are not a reference material
these are actual clinical license
these are we grow it in the lab and we
took the live organism we spite in the
urine transfer to the collection device
in two different concentrations and
incubated at an ambient temperature and
in cold in the requested conditions then
the lies the cells We Run The PCR asset
what is interesting we want to I want to
show you is
at the higher concentration
moreover the period in an ampere
temperature the city value is going down
that's the indication of the organism is
growing we all know that the urine is
nutritious they tend to grow
so why I am showing this
the impact organism live organism when
you include in the validation you can
understand the acid performance really
work
whether the clinically this is going to
affect the patient the answer is no the
reason is most of the organizations are
going to grow when and when we expect in
hundred thousand CA people but it will
give you an idea what is going on in
your assay performance Plus in using
intact organism you are defining not
just PCR include the extraction as well
you know demonstrating you have the
ability to realize the organism and
extract panic attacks
thank you
um Dr Winslow can you please take over
yes
so just to summarize
um
my information and Dr mail's information
I want to State uh that it is very
important UTI diagnostic methods
absolutely matter in the clinic
um so we have the patient we have the
health care provider
the health care provider of course is
going to do a clinical evaluation
but the next step choosing the right
test
for the right patient at the right time
what we know as diagnostic stewardship
is absolutely critical for the clinical
outcomes that we will have on the other
side of the diagnostic test
by choosing a rapid diagnostic test for
urinary tract infection detection
and having that rapid diagnostic result
reported
as well as the right interpretation of
the information the right antimicrobial
choices at the right time will lead to
those positive clinical outcomes that we
want to see from the diagnostic method
that we choose for urinary tract
infection detection
so thank you for joining us today we're
going to now open the floor for
questions
foreign
for your informative presentation we
will now start the live q a portion of
the webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now by
submitting it into the ask a question
box
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
now let's get started
um of our first questions here is was
nucleic acid extraction was it done from
the isolates or from urine specimens
so we expect the organisms in the urine
and we spend down we collectible lack
which can be used for extraction
not from the urine so specimen directly
so that we can avoid any interference
agents in the urine
unique thank you for that
um another question here um clinically
we are taught to not treat um poly
microbial culture or PCR reports what is
the clinical value of treating
polymicrobial PCR reports
great question
um so I think
um the point of that question that's the
most important is treating test results
we don't treat test results
um we want to treat the patient so
the patient should have clinical signs
and symptoms of urinary tract infection
for us to
prescribe and use these test results so
we wouldn't encourage anyone to to treat
uh necessarily just test results
clinically we want to treat the patient
and their clinical signs and symptoms
[Music]
look
up
I couldn't hear Emily
oh apologies
sorry about that yeah I will repeat the
question right now
um please discuss the denials by mole DX
for PCR UTI panels
um Palmetto and moldy X have not
approved any UTI TCR panels for
reimbursement to date even those with a
z code
I'll take that one Dr mayiel
uh in my discussions with moldy X about
uh approval of technical analyzes and
reimbursement uh they this is coming
from them they don't feel that the
literature that is available currently
is sufficient to validate the clinical
utility
of the test
um and they highly encourage the
industry to join together
to produce and publish the data that
they want to see regarding clinical
utility
um so that they can determine to
reimburse this
great thank you
great another question here should the
Xeno Spike and control be added to each
patient sample to ensure amplification
should the extraction control organism
be added to each patient sample to
verify extraction
I will take that question
yes you have to spike the Zeno control
in this case we are using the live
organism the basalusa trophies
so it can serve both
for the extraction control and the
center control
so that's how the system works so
uh if you want to use any other controls
you can but you have to do the
extraction process
that's a requirement
thank you for that
okay another question here um suc
typically identifies organisms at less
than a thousand SFU as the lowest level
of detection with PCR we can identify
organisms down to 5 SB or 50 SP CP
apologies what is significant in
identifying the organisms to this LOD
and what should be the lowest LOD
reported or should we use as our cutoff
uh I will take that question Dr Kevin so
here
in the UTA yes that he said it's a two
sensitive of course but if you use the
open array we call The Sweet Spot
the the reason is when we run the Lodi
we added to we came to the conclusion
that it is not too sensitive because the
ability to control the assay in such a
way that you have the ability to produce
hundred thousand cfu a little bit below
not like 100 cfu parama no
which matches with the CDC and the FDA
recommendation uh CFA values so it's not
too sensitive I say and they can have
the ability to report clinically
relevant organisms in a relevant
concentration
I answer the question correctly
or you need more information on that
okay
we can let them respond
um if they have any further questions
thank you
um here's another one
how does PCR ABR compare to traditional
urine culture results for antibiotic
resistance determination and do you feel
molecular ABR testing has the potential
to replace urine culture in the long run
Maya you want me to take that one
oh please
okay
um so antibiotic resistance testing
gives us a genotype for that organism So
based on the genotype alone we could
possibly assume that the organism is
resistant to that antibiotic but what we
also know is that uh there are many
factors that play into whether a gene
expresses itself phenotypically the same
way
so
antibiotic resistance Gene uh sequencing
I don't feel that it will absolutely
replace urine culture in the long run
because there's like I said so many
other factors that go into whether that
Gene expresses itself
um the other organisms in the microbiome
that may be interacting with each other
and such so that's a short answer for
that one
yes uh I'd like to add a few more things
Dr Winslow uh so when we do the PCR
testing it's not going to be a real time
right is that we are collecting the
material we are going for after the
genetic material correct so maybe the
other organism may be dead but still you
may have the genetic material you are
detecting so at the time
you will not get the appropriate answer
for the clinical treatment it is always
better to the culture and do the ASD
and you can give the right information
you both
some great questions coming in lots to
get through okay another one
um says thank you that was a great
presentation how far can genotypic AMR
go in terms of treatment selection in
other words does AMR resistance Gene
screening go far enough to inform a
treatment plan
uh Dr winksloy
I will take this question
yes the reason of detecting the AMR
antibiotic antimicrobial resistance in
is really good so that you can avoid but
some antibiotics in the yearly stage the
PC results will come yearly so that you
can avoid oh I see the act or AMC I can
avoid these antibiotics
at the same time
the final result coming from the lab
will support the antibiotic selection
so the AMR is not going to replace the
routine testing but at the same time it
will give you an idea what drug you
should not use
thank you
thank you
um and just a reminder to the audience
if we do not get to your question
um they can be they will be answered by
the speakers after the presentation
um another question here
how did you determine what targets are
detected as pathogenic versus normal
flora by PCR
Mayo you want to take that one no
absolutely
yes so uh that's a very good great
question
yes so normally this question comes up
when we are dealing with the choir glass
negative
right so that's the one is going to give
you trouble but when you you have the
assay when you have when you do the
validation
you have to make sure that it reaches
the clinically acceptable uh cfu value
if you do that then you have the ability
to overcome those issues there are some
other bacteria this carnivorous
regularly uh that's a common uh human uh
Flora which may give you trouble
but
you are going to give me a data which is
going to substance that the where the
CFE value is is matches with the
clinically relevance
value and how you run the validation is
going to dictate those things at the
same time of course the clinician is
going to look at the data and the
patient condition before they start of
course it is up to the physician to
decide
thank you thank you
next question
what do you think is the main hurdle for
UTI to be a standard of care as opposed
to suc currently and how do you see PCR
getting there
I'll take that one Dr Mayo yeah please
um working on the clinical side of this
test
um in my personal opinion and based on
um comments I've heard from payers and
such
you know we have standard or prescribers
are taught to use the standard urine
culture
um that is the current uh guideline from
idsa and other uh professional bodies
that provide guidelines on how to
diagnose and how to treat urinary tract
infection
in my opinion I feel like as an industry
we are going to have to educate
uh those guideline makers
so that they can realize the value of
PCR over standard urine culture
um in my experience prescribers are they
like to prescribe by guidelines so if we
can get the PCR into those guidelines
and name where it's appropriate how to
use the test how to read the test Etc I
feel like it's going to be about
education and showing evidence
um to get PCR to be the standard of care
great question and answer thank you
they have some few more questions
um what type of tubes were used for the
validation and what is your opinion on
preservatives tubes for stability
uh I will take that question uh Dr
Winslow yes we use the boric acid tube
containing tubes for the sample
collection and the validation the reason
is our love is a reference lab the
sample you have to come from different
places so the stability is going to play
a role and we use the boric acid use
answer the question
I hope so
another question
and the validation just
familiar with checkerboard what is it it
was stated to use 30 samples per analyze
does that mean 30 samples positive and
negative report or poor organism
okay I don't think that's the question
so you have a two question now the first
question I will answer check up both if
you are using uh automated instruments
for extraction process the first thing
into parts of Mind whether sample is
jumping from one well to another one
so what we do normally for example you
are taking an anticiple plate for
abstraction the Bell one has your sample
you usually expect in hundreds of some
more and hundred thousand or tons of six
cfu Karma kind of high concentration and
the next one you put just what a client
sterile water so it's going to be zigzag
you put
sample controller okay no I can no
sample just water and then again sample
and then water you do it like this and
then demonstrate there is no cross
contamination this experiment we call
Checkerboard
now for the second question
so you are talking about
um
I'm sorry I missed the
yes you need 30 sample per analyte
positive sample which is 15 samples near
the L Body 15 sample should be above the
L Body that means for example 10 000 you
were already 10 000 cfu Primal liver oil
body then you have to use 100 000 LOD uh
hundred thousand cfu per mile is another
15 sample and
30 urine sample you have to use negative
urine sample
so that you can do that two by two table
analysis for the accuracy study
thank you
thank you um another slightly related
question
um does the positive control have to be
for all organisms on the panel
absolutely yes that's a requirement you
have to you have to use but once you
show that uh
even a synthetic DNA can be used for
that purpose it need not to be the in a
full organism if a full organism is good
but you can use synthetic DNA but you
have to demonstrate
including extraction so we are going to
do the extraction and how you are doing
the PCR then you are good to go
thank you I believe we touched on this
earlier um but someone's asking did you
use patient urine specimens for method
validation
yes we use for those things yes of
course
Perfect all right
another few questions here
um someone is asking can you really
justify the cost of Multiplex PCR versus
culture for UTIs
it doesn't seem that the clinic clinical
value can justify the cost especially
considering that some labs are charging
a thousand thousand dollars plus for
these tests
I'll take that one dot Romeo
you know this is how I like to answer
this question because it does come up
I like to ask
um the I like to ask what is the cost of
not doing the PCR test what is the cost
of false negatives
what is the cost of polymicrobial
infections that are not identified
there are many costs that are associated
with the standard urine culture besides
The Upfront cost of the test
so you know the question really goes
back to is the standard urine culture
less expensive if we're not identifying
or we are misdiagnosing urinary tract
infections
um
I know that's it's not a financial
figure it's not digits but that is how I
like to answer that question that
and that comes from the clinical side of
this test the you know the clinician
looking at whether they want to use the
test uh the standard urine culture
versus PCR
um you know what are the clinical
outcomes the negative clinical outcomes
and what do they cost associated with
the standard urine culture
thank you Dr Winslow
and the next question what is your
opinion on spiking and the NTC control
with extraction control organism
uh the ntca should be uh
just to blame sterile water you should
not do anything with that because that
control is to monitor any contamination
from your reagents so you should not do
anything with that
and if you want to do the extraction
control then you have to introduce the
NEC that's why we have any easy negative
extraction control there you can strike
the negative or the spiking organism and
extract and demonstrate you can do the
extraction at the same time the PCR is
working as a specter
it is a clear hope it is clear
foreign
another question
um what collection devices
preservative media would you recommend
for urine testing
uh I will take that question
um
so far
we are using the boric acid tubes
the reason is we are not only doing the
PCR test at the same time we are doing
the culture work
which we call PCR guided AISD so
when you grow the organism
mean normal culture we don't know what
is going on but since we are doing the
PCR we know which organism we have to
look for
so we can leave the plate nor more than
48 hours and look for the organism the
reason is some organism tend to grow
slow
for that reason we are using boric acid
tubes
so it solves both purposes you can do
PCR at the same time you can do the
culture work as well
thank you
thank you next question is how do you
determine the cutoff value
and the validation
another question someone's asking is how
might we identify organisms outside of
the PCR panel
that's a great question uh
yes
so most of the time we are seeing uh
the PCR panel organisms very rarely when
you do the culture very early very when
you do the culture we are noticing some
organisms
of course
recently we encountered some vasana
butter
complex organisms which is very
difficult to identify by the way
and
initially we missed in the PCR course
but since we are doing the culture work
we are giving the necessary information
to the physician
that's how we are managing it to that so
we are not going to miss the organisms
that is going to grow on the culture at
the same time
we are giving the results much faster
than the culture work using the PCR
thank you so we have time for a few more
questions
um another one we have here is would PCR
be a good choice for patients with three
occurrent clinical signs and symptoms of
UTIs whose standard urine shows no
growth
I'll take that one.myu
sure please
um
my answer is absolutely what we're
finding is that
um quite often patients that have
clinical signs and symptoms of urinary
tract infection but their standard urine
culture is negative
uh that the PCR does identify uh an
organism that may be the causative agent
of their clinical signs and symptoms
um so uh yes the short answer is yes
perfect thank you
um the next question is I feel like the
PCR test is too sensitive PCR identifies
microorganisms the medical community
hasn't typically seen reported from
standard urine cultures and I am
concerned about over prescribing
antibiotics when they aren't necessary
what are your thoughts on PCR being too
sensitive
I will take that question
the question is great and I agree with
them
please here is too sensitive yes but
the sensitivity is going to be
determined by what kind of platform you
choose
how much the illusion volume goes into
the PCR reaction this two thing is going
to dictate
track infection testing
I we prefer open array the reason is the
limitations over there which we can use
as a system to do that you're not track
infection which is going to be
from our validation from between ten
thousand two hundred thousand
so it's not too sensitive and we are not
violating any already we established
conference
yeah I'll add I'd like to add on to what
the Dr mayell said as a clinician my
concern would be that I am under
treating
um especially those patients that have
false negatives but have signs and
symptoms of urinary tract infection
those patients often feel unheard uh
they you know are often confused by the
fact that they they know their body they
feel they have the signs and symptoms uh
but the tests are negative
um the standard urine culture is
negative so that's my concern
um or that's what I hear clinicians
saying is that oh my gosh if I think
about how many patients
had a negative standard urine culture
but they continue to have signs and
symptoms you know that bothers me
personally so that's the kind of
feedback that that I'm hearing
from clinicians is
um even the fact that they may have been
under
prescribing for those patients
thank you I have another question here
is normally I empirically prescribe an
antibiotic until the patient's standard
year in culture returns and then based
on the AST I know whether to change the
antibiotic or continue the antibiotic if
PCR test results are available in 24
hours or less should I refrain from
prescribing empirically until after the
PCR results are returned
yeah that's a million dollar question
um but what I'll say is that
the great part about PCR being returned
so quickly such a fast turnaround time
is that a
if the physician or prescriber wants to
wait to prescribe until they get the PCR
results there's a very short turnaround
time
if the prescriber wants to prescribe an
antibiotic in the physician's office
before that patient leaves before any
test results have come back heck before
any of them have been sent out
um they're also able to de-prescribe
at that short turnaround time that
result that comes from PCR testing so
you know let's just say that a
prescriber prescribed
um cetra for a UTI and then when those
PCR test results come back
there's no organism this this is
hypothetical they can de-prescribe that
antibiotic quickly so it's really you
know the Physicians or prescribers
um what works best for their patient
population
thank you Dr Winslow can I end with this
question
um what does the pay or landscape look
like for PCR UTI testing and do payers
reimburse the test or will my patients
have to pay out of pocket
um so I'll take that one
uh the payer landscape is of course it
varies based on the geographic location
of the lab for one
um you know there's so many factors that
go into the payer discussion and whether
payers are paying um that go well beyond
well beyond this conversation
um so the shortest easiest answer is
that it's highly lab dependent
um you know your technical analysis Etc
so I think that's just the best place to
leave that question
thank you
um and thank you again both Dr Winslow
and Dr shimogum for your time today and
your important research
um and do you have any final comments
for our audience
I just want to thank everybody for
joining us I think we had a great
turnout and I really hope this
information
uh gets pushed out to others as a result
how about you Dr Mayo
yes the questions were really nice I was
happy you know that's like this was a
real uh interactive questions thank you
so much
thanks a lot
that's really crazy
yes very interactive thank you both uh
we'd also like to thank lab roots and
our sponsored Thermo Fisher Scientific
for underwriting today's webcast foreign
before we go I like to thank the
audience for joining us today and
further interesting questions
we were unable to answer today and those
that come in during the on-demand period
will be answered via the email address
you provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
Roots alert you via email when it's
available for replay and we encourage
you to share that email with any of your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
thank you until next time goodbye